welcome to the show please take one you
look phenomenal love your costume
enjoy the show hi amazing costume please
take one just one I'll take the whole
basket yes congratulations
what's your name Seth Seth you just
became the 1,000th Conan audience member
to make that exact same joke you want a
lifetime supply of Snickers bar a
lifetime supply that's a lot of Snickers
bars oh maybe not as many as you think
no that's my friend Josh he just wore
this cool costume what's up Josh it's
not Josh wait maybe he's just hungry
you're not you when you're hungry right
mad hot mess hangry cray cray cray cray
whoa thanks for your princess hey bud
you ready to get your Conan on yeah dude
enjoy the show great costumes guys
you're so cute enjoy the show enjoy the
show enjoy the show
amazing Lester I love it don't know what
you are but very cool enjoy the show
[Music]